hey it's jeremy renner hey what's up i'm
don cheadle hello i'm scarlett danai
gurira
chris hemsworth and this is wired's 50
most asked questions
about the avengers let's go you ready
me too what is the purple infinity stone
i think it's an amethyst
not the yellow one what language do they
speak in black panther
over here there you go come on you know
right now it's pronounced
i know that it's not right
no what was the word that you pronounce
word
throw it out not even close
who directed infinity war a couple of
guys named the russos
joe and anthony cute kids get to know
him who can pick up thor's hammer
captain marvel don't you dare oh
oh nobody can captain marvel beat thanos
that's the question we all want to know
the answer to yes sure why not we'll say
yeah
we'll see we don't
[Music]
why was the red skull in infinity war i
think it was like a contractual
obligation
what is thor the god of
hammers no that's what he says i'm not
in light lightning thunder
thunder thunder lightning it's a god of
lightning
i think it's actually thunder or ikea
assembling of furniture is thanos a god
no but josh brolin is have you seen this
area of thanos
do you guys don't look like that uh
who's stronger than thanos
thor what does avenge me
i thought that said one is average mean
and i was like my well
my answers to this to make right
by what happened to thor's eye
got stabbed out by his sister is black
panther marvel
is this even a sentence is the other one
is black panther dc would that be like
the alternate
question of that how strong is captain
america stronger than thor
oh my god can a lightsaber cut through
captain america's shield
that question is entirely too geeky for
me to answer
why are we trying to do like a star wars
versus avengers thing
there's room in the universe for
everybody to exist enjoy your star wars
thing
and then enjoy your avengers thing we
don't care how old is story
173 yeah guys come on guys figure it out
what is an iron man what is an iron man
it's a man made out of iron i don't
think that we uh have to you know
exclude women from this there can be
iron women if you want to be made of
iron you're a woman
you made it mine why does thanos want to
destroy half the universe again
this area um he's angry
traffic if you look like that you would
have a chip on your shoulder
and a ball sack on your neck how did
captain marvel get her powers
uh crack how old is black panther 173 as
well
yeah 173 how strong is the hulk so
strong
there is a bo element to hulk more
aromatic
than a regular person but what does each
infinity stone do
different things um there's like a
purplish one and like a red one
and a yellow one and a green one i think
there's a new one a whole lot of
you know party tricks how many
infinity stones six
each knuckle is he what is he doing
what's his fault he's got an x-ray he's
just
an extra knuckle how tall is the hulk so
tall
so seven four plus about a foot give or
take what
are the infinity stones christmas
decorations
which avenger are you how dare you
[Laughter]
i mean really what is the name of thor's
hammer
mjolnir really really yeah a tough one
to say what to watch before infinity war
ricky lake all of the other movies get
yourself a buttload of popcorn
and jujubes uh juji bears juji
get some of those things and hang out
when was black panther created the comic
book i'm imagining i'd say
the 6 7 what is captain america shield
made of
oh it's made out of um what is it it's
made out of uh
oh jesus i think it's vibranium by
vibranium
what does the end of infinity war mean
this is a very uh philosophical question
honestly infinity's looks like doesn't
that just go on like in like
for infinity it can be a cautionary tale
for asthmatics
get a broom start sleeping wow
or a vacuum how powerful is captain
marvel
powerful is thought how many avenger
movies are there one
two three the third part it's kind of
one and two
four got that one right how old is
captain america
173 or something 60 yeah 165.
how strong is spider-man so strong he is
as strong
as a man would be were he to be imbued
with the strength of a spider do that
calculus in your head
go jeremy all right come on come on come
on
where are the infinity stones
in the gauntlet right now what is thanos
is he an alien
he's a mutant when did infinity war come
out
that's still a question on google when
did infinity war come in
last year last april who are the
avengers that's a pretty deep question
dudes and chicks just kind of hanging
out
saving the world very cool folks man the
avengers
are you invented
[Music]
yeah okay how did thanos get the power
stone
he's a dude that's just how it works
what happens infinity
what i don't know what are captain
marvel's powers
all of them i guess the question is what
aren't
captain marvel's powers a spider-man
marvel or dc
uh marvel what was the symbol at the end
of infinity war
chris evans beard i believe it was the
same symbol that prince
used to use who is black panther
t'challa
yeah uh the amazing chadwick boseman
that's right
who survived infinity war spoiler alert
uh go
see infinity war what happens after
infinity war uh the next movie end game
that's what we're here promoting who
wrote these questions when does avengers
4 come out
march
how to draw the avengers is that a
question that's a google question
carefully and take a lot of time when
you're drawing war machine
because you want to get that one right
there's a lot of detail uh tracing
you know some would say there's cheating
i would say it's we've got 50 questions
efficiency
there's a lot of shading a lot of people
miss that there's subtlety
there's a family of grays you can't just
go gun metal gray and be done with it
don't rush through your war machine
drawing of avengers who all dies in
infinity war
i didn't
oh my god
a lot of people no no no no who all dies
infinite this is ridiculous
thanks for watching wired come to okay
go see your ding movie